j - 6 avant l'open de france de golf la
compétition qui fêtera cette année sa
100e édition sera organisée pendant
quatre jours sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
parcours totalement remodelée cette
année en vue de la ryder cup 2018 en
coulisses on peaufine les derniers
réglages
il ya encore une semaine de travail
après tout les travaux qu'on a fait il
faut pas oublier qu'elle albatros été
fermée pendant neuf mois sur la période
et elle va on a fait 127 km des
tranchées pour bien drainé les parcours
est forcément déçu samedi le mend est
pas qu il y encore de système et encore
le travail à faire et une nouvelle il
nous reste mais mais on est on est on
est très près une quarantaine de
jardiniers des centaines de personnes
sont mobilisées dans la logistique pour
préparer cet événement un travail rendu
difficile avec les conditions
climatiques de ces dernières semaines on
a roulé moins d'ego entre les plots plus
bio ne la gagnait 5,5 comme dans tous
les travaux dans les parcours et pour
plus revoir les lacs et on est connecté
mais la morale des
dahlin et on est vraiment on a mis de
soleil selon les météorologues du golf
national le soleil devrait être de la
partie pour l'open de quoi ravir les
55000 à 60000 spectateurs qui seront
présents sur les quatre jours de
compétition